[Musique]
l'entrée de la bretagne
fougères 26 mille habitants il y a les
souvenirs historiques mais aussi depuis
le siècle dernier une population
ouvrière importante
c'est pourquoi à fougères on est très
attentif à la réforme du smig
comme partout où les salaires sont bas
environ de la moitié de la population de
fougères et salariés le secteur
industriel emploie 7000 personnes
adultes dont 65 % dans l'industrie de la
chaussure et l'habillement sur ses 7000
personnes un millier environ gagnent
entre profs en 27 qui le niveau du smic
est pro france 50 de leurs nets
on peut donc penser qu'une personne sur
sept est directement concerné par
l'évolution d'une mine de plus le niveau
et la structure de nos salaires
professionnel faits que directement ou
indirectement c'est la grande majorité
des travailleurs de fougères qui est
concerné qu'est ce que le smic salaire
minimum interprofessionnel garanti
c'est le salaire horaire en dessous
duquel personne ne doit être payée
depuis 1952 ce salaire était liée à l'
indice des prix son pouvoir d'achat ne
devait pas diminué on disait que ce
salaire minimum et des garanties
hier les députés ont voté nouvelle loi
on avait constaté que les semis gars ne
profitait pas de l'accroissement du
revenu de la nation le gâteau augmenté
mais leur part à eux restés toujours la
même avec la nouvelle loi la part des
smicards devra augmenter comme le gâteau
le smig avec un g devient smic avec un c
salaire minimum de croissance
la loi mettra en place différents
dispositifs qui garantiront cette
croissance rattaché au salaire horaire
moyen le smic ne devra pas accumuler de
retard le fossé ne devra pas se creuser
comme par le passé entre les nouveaux
semis gare et le reste des salariés
cette loi qui doit être appliquée le 1er
janvier touche directement 750000
smigards mais indirectement 2 millions
de petits salariés environ
sont concernés
madame ou du ski travaillait après la
naissance de son premier enfant a dû
cesser après avoir eu deux jumeaux son
mari n'a pas pu utiliser son cap2
boulanger depuis trois ans il est
employé comme ouvrier non qualifié dans
une entreprise de métallurgie de
fougères je crois que vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle un smicard
enfin pas tout à fait dans une école et
un salaire de base de 3 36 de leurs
alors que le smig et de 3,26 jeu pour
326 9 centimes de plus que le smig et
c'est d'ailleurs j'ai aussi une prime de
rendement désolé mais au moins elle
revient dans les environs 65 70 centimes
savary aux fruits savary alors vous avez
donc un salaire de base une prime de
rendement et primes d'ancienneté qui
vais 97 de la ligue en direct et en
complément on a de quoi mettre manif
rang d'allocations familiales les
tractations plus que ça véronique plus
allocations logement seydoux qui
s'ajoutent au salaire net
alors tout ça ça fait exactement ce que
vous avez à dépenser dans le noir ville
qui fait 11220 38 112 112 me d'anciens
prendre il savait que ça nous arrive et
on se sent m
en 120 francs là on a des frais fixes
qui consiste dans le loyer 150 points
les assurances 80 francs on ne le gaz
électricité 50 francs le chauffage 25
francs l'entretien de la voiture
les 140 francs le crédit
suivant les suivants les moments parce
qu'évidemment il va toujours un crédit
45 franc rapidement 80 francs et la
cantine de l'école du plus grand
puisqu'il va à l'école 50 francs ce qui
fait ce qui fait comme dépenses
obligatoires
environ 530 francs +10 francs d'impôt
immobilier que j'ai oublié tout à
l'heure il reste donc pour vivre poids
nourriture pour l'entretien de la maison
environ 600 francs alors me voilà
nourriture payée
qu'est ce qu'il vous reste il reste rien
comment faites vous si par exemple votre
marié mal à 2004 si quelqu'un est malade
nous sommes mariés ou non cela pose un
gros problème parce qu'on est obligés de
rogner sur quelque chose et comme on
choisit son sursis sur 300 francs
puisqu'on ne peut pas prendre sur les
préfixes s'explique et vous avez sans
doute vu que dans notre budget il n'y a
ni loisirs donc le comprends pas de
loisirs division on n'a pas la
télévision
on n'a pas en années frigola pas machine
à laver
il n'y a pas d'investissement de compris
dans le budget parce que pouvoir oui on
a aussi beaucoup plus jeune - aide le
même salaire pour moi je suis certain
qu'ils ont à la base par exemple je suis
au rsa
alors je vais 23,36 dollars mais
certains m'ont 3 20 en dessous du smig
oui mais étant donné que le smi est
compris avec le salaire réel
le salaire l ai compris alors avec la
avec les primes de rendement dans ces t
il des machines à l'avenir à grappes le
smur et veut dire que votre augmentation
à vous qui êtes foutus 10 mis des
ailiers augmentation du smig horrible
parce que s'il a sonné l'heure augmente
paris sombre 2%
personnellement j'ai une augmentation de
borce enfin les délégués le monde moi
grâce
les délégués manteau de haut un peu dire
la résolution purent enfin en principe
qu'on arrive quand même à avoir pour
faire l'équivalent du smic alors si le
smi l'augmenter 2% et 2%
nous allons passer ensemble nous avons
proposé à madame et monsieur opus de
venir s'entretenir avec le ministre du
travail dans son bureau de la rue de
grenelle monsieur fontanet l'auteur de
la réforme du smig les reçoit comment
vous feriez leur établir un budget avec
11 104 ans si vous aviez trois enfants
oui madame
je crois que vous devriez déjà pouvoir
répondre puisque vous y parvenez mais je
me rends compte que ça suppose de votre
part un effort extraordinaire et par
conséquent je pense qu'il est
souhaitable que l'on fasse le maximum de
façon à vous permettre de disposer de
ressources accrues dans la nouvelle
formule d'évolution du salaire minimum
permettra à ceux qui reçoivent les
salaires les plus faibles de voir leur
situation s'améliorer dans la même
proportion que les autres c'est à dire
que il y aura pour eux d'année en année
un gain de pouvoir d'achat
s'il ya vraiment amélioration du smic
qu'en pensez-vous que par exemple nous
pouvons nous payer une machine à laver
oui madame voyez-vous le salaire minimum
tel qu'il est fixé actuellement c'est
vraiment le salaire le plus bas c'est à
dire celui en dessous duquel personne ne
peut être payés mais il est bien évident
que il est souhaitable qu'il y ait des
possibilités d'amélioration du sort de
tous ceux qui réussissent à acquérir un
supplément de qualification nous ferons
en sorte que ce salaire minimum lui-même
comme je viens de vous le dire augmente
le plus rapidement possible seulement ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que si on
voulait aller trop vite
vous avez des régions dans lesquelles il
y à des activités
professionnels qui ne sont pas
extrêmement productive et où
l'augmentation massive du salaire
minimum risquerait de provoquer des
fermetures d'entreprises et du chômage
ou sujet de cette progression du smi qui
ne doit pas être trop rapide
un délégué syndical de fougères et moi
vous poser une question pourquoi
précisément le nouveau smig
autrement dit le smic n'est-il pas ne
sera-t-il pas totalement indexée au
salaire horaire moyen est pourquoi cette
marge de manoeuvre
portel sur les travailleurs les plus
défavorisés ce qu'il faut bien voir
c'est qu'il y a des périodes où il est
nécessaire que le gouvernement pour
arrêter l'anciennement de la hausse des
prix et des salaires et on sait bien que
dans la course des salaires et des prix
les salaires sont toujours perdants et
surtout les salaires des moins favorisés
il faut que le gouvernement puisse
disposer dans certaines circonstances
d'une marche de jeu et c'est celle que
ce texte ait voulu les ménager mais même
si une année il a fallu user de cette
marge
il y aura par la suite un rattrapage de
telle manière qu en longue période
le salaire minimum évolue bien en
concordance en harmonie avec l'ensemble
des autres salaires
oui nous parler de longue période mais
il faudrait savoir et longue période ça
veut dire l'ont donc aux biens année ça
peut éviter aussi bien en 20 ans non je
veux dire sur une cible et si une année
on a été obligé de faire jouer cette
possibilité de ne pas répercuter
totalement les éléments d'amélioration
du salaire minimum et bien c'est l'année
suivante qu'il faudra que je joue le
rattrapage vous avez dit tout à l'heure
le sioniste que vous vouliez que plus le
smig ne manque pas trop vite pour éviter
que dans certains cas il y ait des
risques de chômage pour une question qui
est posée par un délégué syndical de
fougères cette question part de
l'observation du temps de travail réel
effectué par mois dans la chaussure à
fougères depuis la création du smig le
passage fréquent est assez régulier de
la cour en dessous de la ligne des 40
heures montrent à l'évidence
l'existence d'un chômage partiel on va
donc aussi même si le salaire horaire
est garanti le salaire mensuel ne l'est
pas pourquoi ne pas avoir créé un smig
minimum mensuel
la question a été soulevée par les
organisations syndicales au moment des
débats sur la préparation du projet de
loi actuel et le gouvernement n'a pas
dit qu'il était opposé à une solution de
ce genre mais nous avons renvoyé
l'étude de ce problème à un groupe
d'experts qui est chargée d'étudier tous
les problèmes de la mensualisation et
qui doit nous donner sa réponse fin
février vraiment un problème tout à fait
sérieux quand même surtout dans la
région fougeraise même péter pinda
moi j'ai une voisine par exemple la
semaine dernière elle a fait 16 heures
de travail elle achemine l'instant la
semaine la semaine d'avant elle a fait
24 heures et depuis le mois de septembre
hicham terriblement et l'avenir n'est
pas brillant du tout ils valent rien et
aux perspectives alors si bien que ces
gens là ont des revenus même avec toutes
ses unités de chômage des revenus
annuels qui sont bien en dessous même du
smig
oui c'est qu'elles ont déjà des années
mme dit et le chômage partiel mais qui
sont inférieures à ce que serait un
minimum mensuel garanti au niveau du
smic horaire x 40 heures mais ce que je
voudrais vous dire voyez vous c'est qu'
il ne faut pas négliger
et je reviens sur un point que nous
avons évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure
ce qui peut provenir de l'effort
personnel individuel d'un travailleur
pour améliorer sa protection sa
situation
au delà de ce que cette protection
légale collective que représente le
salaire minimum peut lui apporter
et vous savez nous avons actuellement
des moyens de formation professionnelle
qu'ils sont
développé et qui sont accompagnés d'une
mesure extrêmement intéressante qui est
la possibilité pour ceux qui suivent ces
stages d'être payés pendant les stages
alors pour nous il me semble que ce soir
presque impossible étant donné qu on en
perçoit une allocation de toi 27 de
leurs pour 40 heures alors avec notre
budget c'est quand même assez court si
je comprends bien vous avez néanmoins
déjà actuellement un certain nombre de
primes qui s'ajoutaient votre salaire et
ses primes que vous avez peur de perdre
même si vous retrouvez en stage
l'équivalent de votre salaire de base
alors je comprends bien seulement voyez
vous il faut peut-être que vous calcule
y est aussi s'il en acceptant un certain
manque à gagner pendant quelques mois
vous n'avez pas par la suite les chances
de promotion professionnelle et à ce
moment-là d'amélioration de salaire qui
vous permettrait de regagner au delà ce
manque à gagner que vous auriez dit à
venir consentis mais madame houdusse
vous avez 24 ans le cheveu du ce vous
avez 26 ans
comment vous voyez votre avenir pas très
brillant parce que comme my pop erreur
une promotion deuxièmement quand les
enfants soient élevés je serai obligé de
travailler si on veut arriver à voir
quelque chose parce qu'avec le salaire
que qui la plus probable est donc pas
qu'on peut pas vivre et vous avez
convaincu forcément brighton la corse la
seule solution mais c'est pas très droit
parce que quand vous avez des enfants
qui sont jeunes et qu'il faut aller trop
payés mais l'éducation des enfants en
prendre un coup forcément parce que les
enfants vont atteindre un certain âge
c'est évidemment les dépenses en moins
comme est beaucoup plus élevé face
colère et et tout augmente en proportion
or l'on n'irait pas du tout cas je
travaille là il à faire
[Musique]